we must mobilize the market current
commitments are not enough we need
public money we need private money we
need philanthropic money
it's no secret that limiting global
warming is going to cost a lot of money
but just how much is still a sticking
point 131 trillion dollars between now
and 2050 is one answer according to the
international renewable energy agency
much more than previously estimated
for context the world's gdp was nearly
85 trillion dollars last year
of course it's basically impossible to
estimate the final cost but the world is
trying to figure out how to meet the 1.5
degrees celsius goal set out in the
paris agreement amongst other
commitments
the whole economic system will need to
adapt and align with the climate
objectives
it's a huge bill that would have to be
split between governments businesses and
consumers so we broke it down to
understand where the money needs to go
first we'll need to phase out fossil
fuels
according to this report 24 trillion
dollars in planned investment in fossil
fuels will need to be redirected to
energy transition technologies
carbon price and a carbon tax is what
has been highlighted as the main
instrument we should develop to
facilitate the transition
economist deny kiryakapulu studies
climate and economic development she
says there are a number of ways the
world could pay to phase out fossil
fuels although so far governments have
been reluctant to raise taxes
subsidies taxes direct investments
regulation all needs to be adjusted to
incentivize this transition many experts
for example say rich countries should
help poor countries pay to phase out
fossil fuels and governments would have
to retrain fossil fuel workers for new
jobs in clean energy sectors
investment in new energy systems would
make up the bulk of the 131 trillion
dollar price tag
116 trillion dollars would go to things
like efficiency electrification and new
technologies designed to help clean
energy solutions become economically
viable
this amount is covering
the cost in infrastructure
the cost for ensuring more energy
efficiency and the deployment of
renewables and greenhouse and
sustainable biomass but new technologies
including sucking carbon out of the
atmosphere through carbon capture and
using waste to generate power may
actually turn out not to provide any
large-scale solutions at all
and estimates for those ideas like green
hydrogen to fuel trucks and aircraft are
based on how much we think they will one
day cost
spending this much money over the next
30 years would require commitments from
the public and private sectors
but there is some debate about how much
money each sector should provide
clearly the private sector has far more
money than governments in their ability
to be able to
move on this right now governments are
negotiating investment packages and
spending and investors are pouring money
into sustainable funds
finance has a crucial role to play in
this transition it is a very powerful
lever that policy makers have to direct
financial flows away from harming
activities to
activities and sectors that support this
transition but while the financial
system is a very powerful lever it is
not enough by itself investors will also
have one eye on unpredictable energy
prices recently the prices of oil and
natural gas have risen laying bare the
world's continued dependence on fossil
fuels
and many worry about the destruction of
jobs in these industries
even though it is something that will
require a lot of investment there are
returns to this there are benefits there
will be new jobs and it is the growth
story of the 21st century and if we do
not invest
the cost will be even higher
at the current rate of emissions
scientific models predict that the earth
will warm by a potentially dangerous 2.7
degrees celsius by the end of the
century compared to pre-industrial
levels
well above the 1.5 degrees celsius
target that would limit the impact of
climate change and that most countries
have said they aim to hit we have
today
all the technologies that we need for
fighting climate change and be
consistent with the paris agreement the
market is already driving us to a new
energy system that will be dominated by
renewables so the how the english may
say the direction of travel is clear